[Music]
from Bryan Singer the director with a
mutant power to make Brett Ratner
disappear comes x-men Days of Future
past the first class wasn't enough
prequel for you and Last Stand wasn't
last enough for you they experienced the
prequel sequel that made the worst x-men
movie irrelevant and the worst Wolverine
movie into a bad dream it's okay it's
all gone now Shea to a time when
humanity and mutants alike are trapped
in a Tron Legacy prison where only the
plot of Terminator 2 can save them as an
indestructible badass gets sent back in
time without his clothes to protect a
vulnerable young man with long hair who
will one day become a leader and stop a
shape-shifter from destroying the future
who sent you you did the person who sent
me was you the world full of other cool
x-men meet Wolverine for the seventh
time Hugh Jackman returns to the role he
could play nicely by now
which he does watch as he sent back to
alter history the only way he knows how
spoiler alerts you're never gonna be
good friends it's been a lot of years
trying to bring you down bub I wish you
must help us do it in the future
I'm a hit no I spend the other half of
your time with characters like Charles
Xavier
the young mutant heroin addict Hank
McCoy is an abler electrification mr.
dose Quicksilver a mutant so powerful he
could single-handedly solve every
problem the x-men will ever have which
is probably why they leave man home and
mystique a mutant so stubborn she'd
rather cause the apocalypse than listen
to reason she's your blood your genes to
create a weapon that wipes us all out
please do not make us the enemy today
get out of my head Charles if you kill
Trask you'll be creating countless more
just like and I'll kill them too when
your psychic friend his mortal enemy and
a dude from the future are all telling
you the same thing you should probably
listen to him idiot
so get ready for a super-powered snuff
film where everyone dies
but also nobody dies and witness and
epilogue the ties up all loose ends
we're all your favorite x-men show up
alive and well which totally undermines
the stakes of x-men apocalypse but who
cares this thing was awesome
top that Avengers starring PowerPoint
magnets how do they work the flash
refers Austin Powers
storm Thurmond Misty's Kelsi syntax old
neato
Megamind the other gay ellen i'm tahni
Ron Burgundy and Ultron x-men Timecop so
if this movie takes place in 1973 and
Wolverine Origins takes place in 1986
Charles is going to go from this to this
and 13 years
yikes be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers Barbra Streisand I now
know why you cry but it's something I
can never do Admiral better be whales
here Kevin I like pie
I am the Mockingjay somebody farted